seid ihr bereit unter kopf ein bisschen
von der sap sich eigentlich hatten wir
gerade schon perfekten anfangen
dann müssen wir jetzt noch mal machen
weil frank der turm an den schon aus
dieser kommentar bei prosieben
danke für den tollen toren theorie
könnte es dann insider werden schreibt
man doch das video also das video ist
zwar ganz in ordnung aber ein zu sagen
danke an die uri der todes wieder klasse
[Musik]
hey das geht ab märz bekommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch
jedes gut lächelt und zwar kam vor ein
paar tagen ein video das schlechteste
essen auf der lippe who hörst lieferando
lieferanten kennt wahrscheinlich jeder
von euch ist eine lieferdienste liu ist
sag ich mal die konkurrenz davon
ich habe zuletzt wieder aufschwung sagt
die branche hat nämlich alle möglichen
anbieter wie vorab itsax.de wie verhält
und macht es da nicht alles gab
ausgekauft das einzige was wir in köln
halt noch zusätzlich haben ist und ich
persönlich muss auch sagen dass ich mehr
so in der lippe fällen geworden bin
einfach weil ich meiner meinung nach
bessere label finde bessere anbieter ist
doch mal ein bisschen teurer aber als
youtube kennt man sich das natürlich
weil man es manchmal auch steuerlich
absetzen kann sonst würde ich es beiden
jahren machen ich habe auf dem weg zu
meinem lieblings leben wo ich immer weiß
dass es lecker ist und bei lieferanten
habe ich kämpfe das schon mal schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht auf jeden fall kann
man essen ist der erste partner freuen
das schlechteste essen und in die
kommentare im annex macht doch bitte
auch mal das beste essen und wir haben
uns für heute abend ausgesucht wir haben
jetzt 20 uhr wir haben und auch sage
bestellen wir doch einfach mal den
besten berger auf die linderung
es ist den besten berger auf lieferando
de wer hätte es gedacht wie schon gesagt
also ich will auch ganz
ich will auch gar nicht lange lagern
liegen andere ist halt immer zwei euro
günstiger
und wir schauen mal was war so heute an
produkten bekommen und ob lieferando
vielleicht sogar besser ist als die limo
obwohl es wichtiger ist halt so macht
man natürlich im geschmackstest also ich
habe schon ausgewählt werde jetzt nicht
nur mir das ganze nacht wird wertung
also leute das bestbewertete hier ist
ein 2 das ist krass gut bewertet kann
man das hat 236 bewertungen und sie sind
fünf sterne komplett umstellen da wusste
ich gar nicht dass es das überhaupt gibt
und hier nehme ich jetzt mal das weil
sie nicht die fördermenge hat sich ganz
gut annehmen wir noch mit cola dazu
meinetwegen sondern bei 11 euro und
pommes werden halt auch nicht schlecht
obwohl die skis bürger menü da müssen ja
eigentlich kommen uns dabei sein
ach so lieber sehen als wenn wir das
schießpulver menü mit süßkartoffeln 12 +
co oder 150 150 extra genau 13 euro in
den warenkorb jetzt nehmen wir noch
irgendwie eine kleinigkeit dazu und dass
er irgendwas günstiges braucht nicht
kommen so kohler
und daran bestellen war das ganze eben
mit paypal perfekt funktioniert perfekt
also hier muss ich auch sagen 16 euro 20
für seine bürger menü ist schon ganz
viele 4
ich bin mal gespannt ob das bei den
löwen teurer wird ich würde eigentlich
sagen ungefährlich bestellungen
verarbeitet abgeschickt nice die
lieferung zeit beträgt 25 minuten na ja
das ist ja schon mal gut
okay der erste bürger von lieferant
ausgestellt jetzt wird mir auch mein
liebling smartphone und öfter mal die
app den beruf bin ich mal gespannt was
am besten bewertet ist so berger fertig
am besten bewertet
und hier haben wir den bürgern karl
hermanns wo ich sogar schon mal essen
war ob die beim liefern auch so gut und
welche nicht der bürger dort den fand
ich eigentlich nice hier nehme ich jetzt
auch einfach mal den cheeseburger der
kostet 10 euro mit break mit käse
natürlich zum warenkorb hinzufügen okay
man muss dazu mit supertramp und erwarte
man haben wir nicht bei lieferando auf
16 eur 25 8 16 eur 20 für so einen
burger menü wir sind ja auch bei 2025
all das jetzt krass leute das heißt der
preis bei beiden genau der gleiche jetzt
entscheidet sich nur am geschmack was
dann wirklich besser ist ok ich hab'
gestellt konnten 25 bis 35 minuten an
irgendwie könnte man auch denken und der
bürger kommt aus dem gleichen laden
kommt genauso schnell an kostet genauso
viel also ihr wollt jetzt auch noch den
cheeseburger dazu irgendwann spät denn
heute ich kann doch nicht schafft den
erster ist da hatten wir schaffen ja
[Musik]
die style ja wir haben eine fünf sterne
von lieferando ich muss sagen es gibt
schon mal ganz gut ich mache es aber mal
noch nicht auf oder von steuer absetzen
[Musik]
also haben natürlich auch ein bisschen
er bei lieferando bestellt aber es ist
auch er angekommen
und jetzt schauen wir mal wie lange die
lippen sagt braucht weil die
lieferzeiten waren ja beide mit 25
minuten angegeben
12 sekunden später sollte der nächste
ist auch da
er muss jetzt eigentlich eine gute
clevere tüte land haben also leute der
leben muss auch da kam das ist aktuell
und hier war irgendwie doch noch den
abstieg bestell diesen job das kann hier
wenigstens in seiner tüte finde ich
immer ganz nice sondern papiertüte
möchte jemand von euch die papiertüte
sollte ich hab noch nicht rein guckt ich
bin jetzt mal gespannt wie die optisch
aussehen und ob wir da einen unterschied
haben hier anscheinend pommes und
bürgerin kein bisschen mehr dass man
hier mit anfangen ok also das hier ist
lieferando passiert eigentlich aus oder
und sie den bürger gar nicht richtig
bewusst was wir zusagen in ordnung
die süßkartoffel also ihr wisst ja preis
vor der gleiche jetzt kommen wir mal zu
den pommes und buben ja gut dann halt
andere com ist es geht ja auch
eigentlich in den burger und der sieht
hier der ist noch mal extra eingepackt
das geht doch mal das hier gut aussah
also da sind wir jetzt am höhepunkt des
videos angelangt ich habe mit dem mann
oder solche die für anfang januar also
vom aussehen her muss ich schon mal
sagen gefällt mir der eigentlich besser
da sieht irgendwie ich finde der sich
halt könnte und so ein bisschen wie so
ein ganz standard bürger aus den man
überall kriegt einem brötchen und so
also ist jetzt nichts außergewöhnliches
und was ich auch anmerken muss der salat
ist bisher der wird so ein bisschen
braun schon das nicht so naiv aber ich
bin ja ein ziemlich großer burger fehlen
deswegen würde ich sagen wir probieren
war auch die bürger soße ist glaube ich
so aus dem supermarkt ohne soße weiße
das
also ich muss sagen schmeckt nicht
schlecht aber ihr wisst ja burger ist
eigentlich mein lieblingsessen und ich
habe in meinem leben 80 prozent aller
bürger die ich probiert habe zwar nicht
besser als den man auch sagen es ist
wahr doch bekommen ist echt nice wenn
ich in burgers benoten müsste würde ich
sechs von zehn punkten geben also es
haut mich nicht um deswegen kommen jetzt
mal zum die limburger hier bin ich auch
mal gespannt
der ist halt ein bisschen fleißiger
glaube ich seid ihr bereit und der
tropfen bisschen
zwar wäre es heftig das merkt man auch
direkt dass das viel bessere qualität
ist was guckst du so habe ich dachte mir
so leid dass ich probiere nicht sagen
der ist so genial etwa und auch die
pommes dazu ich habe selten so ein
bürger wissen eindeutig jetzt mal ohne
spaß was ich muss erst den mund nehmen
das ist wirklich eine 10 von 10 ich kann
ich den laden empfehlen karl-hermann da
war ich auch schon mal so essen ich muss
aber sogar sagen dass der mir jetzt noch
besser schmeckt als wohl schon mal da
war ich besser als bürgerlich sogar
besseres bürgerlich und das ist jetzt
natürlich kritisch bei bürgerlich war
ich früher in köln fast jede woche drei
mal weil das war so mein laden der hat
dazu gemacht denn dort kann man damit
gleich sitzen also der ist wirklich
genial kann ich euch an filmen wenn ihr
meinen köln seit jack ma den laden ab
oder lasst euch halt einfach liefern
[Musik]
du willst du dir mal probieren sind wie
die nicht so gut oder wenn ich mir jetzt
an das letzte lieferando größte live
video zurück erinnern ich glaube haben
wir da gesagt die pizzen davon soll über
einordnung der ist also da hat auch die
level gewonnen und hier also das war ein
welten unterschied der eu auf jeden fall
also ich freue mich jetzt so diesen
bürger auf zu essen und dem 15
geschmacklich okay aber du hast schon
recht ich glaube dass die produkte ja
also ich frag mich da wirklich wie das
auf fünf sterne weil die für andere
kommen konnte keine ahnung das was wird
im video schreibt mir eure ideen und
wünsche für weitere partner die
kommentare und ja hautreinigung ab 36 vj
und ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt nicht zu
sehr hunger auf den leckeren burger